I would love to have her arm too oh you
can have you can borrow my own oh yeah
can I yeah maybe I can have it on like
Mondays Wednesdays yeah and I could have
empathy on Saturdays
[Music]
I've been using the word Unforgettable
it really is Unforgettable yeah
emotional roller coaster a great ending
to a Trilogy it's what we planned from
the beginning and I think it's just so
emotional and beautiful climactic
[Music]
probably Drax I would like to just be as
strong as Heroes and just be able to
destroy anything I touch that'd be cool
mantis is power and power seems to be
empathy and I think that's something
that we need more of in the real world
and that's like the the best sort of
actually humanly accessible superpower
there is I think rock is so smart I mean
he can invent anything he can do
anything that he wants to I'm gonna go
mantis because empathy is always a good
thing I feel like we all need it
foreign
[Music]
[Laughter]
the dead pad nature he delivers them and
also it's just like absolutely hilarious
you and drags together when I watched
the movie it was mantis and Drexel and
making me laugh the most hands down I
mean it's such a good Duo you know such
a great Dynamic Karen like as nebula
gets to be like really funny in this one
and much more vulnerable
[Music]
I think it'd be uh do as your mum says
eat more zard nuts
think less act more destroy everyone in
your way to saving the Galaxy don't let
the motion get in the way for me
compassion the Guardians throughout the
series have learned to have compassion
for themselves and others and animals
and if we had a lot more compassion in
this world I think we'd be in a much
better place that is the truth
[Music]
thank you